over 1.5 million people in Florida are
banned from voting for life because
they've committed felonies that's about
10 percent of the state's population
desmond mead is one of them he recently
got well over the 766 thousand
signatures needed to get an amendment on
the florida ballot that could restore
voting rights back to most former felons
the point that really drove things over
the Angelus when my wife ran for office
about a few years later and I couldn't
even vote for it takes an American
citizen to be able to cast a ballot not
being able to do that is a constant
reminder that we're second-class
citizens Florida is one of only three
states that permanently bans former
felons from voting I was in prison for
19 years 19 years and I have 20 years of
probation I want people to know that
people that commit crimes change
everyday if someone commits a crime they
shouldn't be punished for the rest of
your life to get the right to vote back
in Florida you have to complete your
sentence Perl and probation five to
seven years after that you can submit an
appeal to the Florida Board of executive
clemency the application waiting process
may take up to ten years then you may
have to travel to Tallahassee to attend
a hearing oh and you also have to
provide employment history letters of
recommendation disclose mental health
issues drug use and even traffic
violations after all that the board can
still say no without any reason they
call your name and you're basically re
interrogating in front of an audience
full of people in front of everybody
they're judged on something that you did
many years ago or in my case I think it
was almost 15 years and actually asked
about events of the night of my arrest
after leaving prison
Desmond went through drug treatment and
eventually law school but he still can't
sit for the Florida Bar Exam because the
state denied his application to restore
his civil rights he's devoted his career
to helping others like himself navigate
the system he holds workshops and
retreats to empower prisoners reentering
society we're kind of beaten down here
in the Bible Belt
we've got this kind of like
nineteen sixties mentality still and I
had no idea that these progressive
things and these this reform had been
implemented in other states and that is
successful florida's voting restrictions
were passed during the Jim Crow era the
effects can still be seen today 21% of
black residents in Florida can't vote
these type of laws were used to prevent
african-americans from participating in
the democratic process there's no
escaping that because this have been
left unchecked for so many years
that now more than just African
Americans are impacted and this is about
democracy our country is built on the
premise that every person should have a
say whether we agree with him or not
we are fighting just as hard for that
guy who wants to vote for Donald Trump
as we were fighting for that guy who
wished to the voted for Barack Obama
inside Florida's prisons education
programs like this GED class help
prisoners navigate the US government and
stay up to date with current events and
mates are helpful their rights will be
restored by the time they're out it's
important they are thankful I think
everybody on the right I believe in it
oh when I get out I could
Isis isn't alright it feels like you're
just not part of this country